but irregardless of the actual story
what is certain is that the sufis in
Yemen very quickly realized that this
new beverage was very useful for their
mystical practices the sufis who are
often referred to as Islamic Mystics are
known for their characteristic rituals
and practices they did and still do
often gather together in sessions called
hadra where they will take part in
various forms of very intense Devotion
to God from praying to to meditating
listening to and playing music and the
most characteristic ritual which is
known as Vicor or
remembrance as this can be very
challenging and tiring of course the
sufis of Yemen realized that the very
strong caffeine effect of coffee was
very useful to stay awake and alert
during their long vicker sessions at
night